mr. Roy a pleasure to welcome you home
Oh real cold people showing up here when
I laugh it's pretty touching episode to
make because Brian Cox the actor comes
from Dundee in Scotland he was a guy
driving around places that he knew from
his youth as he plays Logan being a guy
driving around places that he knows from
his youth so it was very affecting to
see that this place you look at the old
pictures and the old one you two think
it's all so [ __ ] simple but it wasn't
[Music]
what they say in the writers room we
always knew there was an element of
tragedy in his early life what am I
supposed to do I think maybe a photo
they've said you can go in no thank you
let's go
ah memories Marsha you look lovely
oh thank you ah so something I wanted to
ask you
Marsha she doesn't come from the same
cultural background as the rest of the
characters and so the rhythms are
slightly different
are you regularly tested for sexually
transmitted diseases excuse me he and I
still sleep together so I will be more
relaxed to know that you are pleased and
I think she shocks people and puts them
on their heels it was interesting to see
her do that to Ray this is appropriate
to talk I mean I loose the other one
[Music]
rare organises what we call the low gana
thon she thinks it would be nice I don't
know whether she's white judged exactly
things that Logan prizes in life which
are generally about going forward not
huge on the past it's a pleasure to have
you here tonight to honor my dad's life
and work
asked me to help out with a little
tribute to the certain flavor
the idea of Kendall rappin's remembers
thinking if you heard a billionaires son
had done that it'd be like yeah it
sounds like the sort of toe-curling
thing you might see on Instagram it was
nice and we had that whole DNA and
Dundee that was full of background
people and people just responded
naturally think it's pretty embarrassing
it's also kind of good
[Music]
you